Aaron is in California when would it be
appropriate to ask your girlfriend or
your boyfriend about their financial
status debt credit score etc and what
would be the appropriate way to ask
Thanks
well it's a great question you're asking
a guy who's been married for almost 40
years so I don't know if you're I need
to be giving any dating advice but you
know it is a I remember when my kids 15
years ago were teenagers what they call
it a define the relationship moment or
something is that what they called it
yeah a DTR define the relationship yeah
and so that's kind of the point here I
mean so I think it's probably a little
bit nerdy to do this on the first date
like hey what's your good score babe you
know I'm on the du rims the envelope
system or whatever but some people do
that and if they're dating another Dave
Ramsey person everybody thinks it's cool
they high-five and and and you know
they're off to marital bliss right but
but otherwise this it kind of pretty
much comes off like you're a super nerd
so you know I you know I think if the
relationship is getting enough that you
think it's going to go somewhere you
start talking about a lot of things that
are important the statistics tell us in
research and I think I've found it to be
true in common sense over the years that
couples that agree on four areas prior
to being married have a very high
success ratio in their marriage
take out any one of these four and it
goes down take out two of them and it
goes way down the number one thing
couples need to be in agreement on
before they get married is money what
we're gonna do with it because it's the
number one thing people fight about how
are we gonna handle debt savings
vacations are we gonna spend everything
on Friday night we make the check on
Friday afternoon thank God it's Friday
oh god it's Monday we're gonna be
children all our lives Yolo baby you
only live once right and so if you're
gonna live if you're gonna marry one of
those you need to know it and be ready
to make a lot of money because they
think they're in Congress and
so that's what you're facing so you've
got it you know you kind of got to know
this going in you need to be in
agreement about money and I honestly
wouldn't know if you're serious
different value systems all sarcasm
aside I would not marry somebody on the
money piece the second one is in loss
every family has crazy in it and
sometimes it's closer than others and
sometimes there's more of it than others
and so you need to go what a boundaries
look like I was talking through a young
man that was getting ready to get
married or thinking about getting
married awhile back and his mom raised
him single mom and had been through a
nasty divorce and I said so what happens
if you're in she was struggling
financially I said what if she happens
if she gets in trouble financially he
goes oh she just moved in with us and I
said have you discussed that with your
potential future wife when he did and
she said that he said that his future
potential wife was no longer his future
potential wife she didn't know he didn't
know how to set boundaries Oh mom does
live with us yeah and his wife is
potential girlfriends and no that ain't
gonna happen and that ended that
relationship so you need to know about
the in-laws you need to know about kids
that's the other one are you gonna have
kids I want to have 14 I want to have
one well you got a bit of a disparity
here you need to think about it we're
not gonna have any we both agree okay
there you go you got it that's cool you
know you need to be in agreement about
this because one of you is gonna be
perpetually dissatisfied if you don't
enter an agreement with that and the
last one is religion you need to be in
agreement about it people that are in
Christianity we call it don't be
unequally yoked but in other religions
they call it different things but the
Uni if you have vast discrepancies about
how you think the universe works and
what you think God is or if there is one
you're going to struggle in your
marriage so marriage our money in-laws
kids and religion if you can be an
agreement on those things so the answer
to your question that is when would you
talk about religion in your dating
process when would you talk about
in-laws when you start talk
about having kids I'd be a little weird
on the first date right and so don't be
strange right so um that's the thing so
I guess as you're getting closer is when
you would do that right and I and I
don't know for some people in some
situations that's faster than others but
I don't know that there's necessarily a
formula but you know normal people would
not do that until they begin to have a
tighter relationship and it looked like
it had a future to it because otherwise
it's a casual dating relationship and
you really don't want to disclose your
you know your life at that level at that
point that's not what it's for it's a
casual thing
so that it's an opinion of an old guy
who doesn't know how to date so there
you go it's worth in this worth what you
paid for it